welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part one the
seventh installment of what I consider
to be the most consistently good
Hollywood franchise and now Tom Cruise
takes the impossible mission of getting
audiences to go to Cinemas and forget
that this was the movie he yelled at a
crew for breaking covet protocol we are
not shutting this movie down but hey I
had fun watching this and I'm gonna
break down some great details and
callbacks to the Past films that you
might have missed the film opens on the
Russian submarine the Sebastopol as we
hear Russian voices transitioning into
English a translation convention for
movies that we also saw in the Russian
sub Espionage film The Hunt for Red
October the two halves of the key come
together to unlock the Vault containing
the server for the computer that
contains the source code for the evil
McGuffin of this movie The Entity an AI
that can corrupt any computer network
and manipulate the very nature of
reality the fact that the key halves
form the cruciform shape is just really
appropriate because it's a Christian
symbol unlocking a soulless God Tech the
Russian says the active learning defense
system we are testing is operating
flawlessly or one like to say
miraculously the fact that all this
could come from some Divine Source
remind us how in Mission possible 3 they
imbued the MacGuffin as a kind of God
Particle it has this mysterious Divine
voice and we don't really know what it
does the Russian says that this is
Operation which translates to Horseshoe
another good luck token we're calling
the rabbit's foot from Mission
Impossible 3. I'm sure the 9th or tenth
Mission Apostle movie is gonna be
chasing after the four-leaf clover
effect the Russian voice says that
they're navigating the polar ice cap by
dead reckoning the one time we hear the
phrase in the movie dead reckoning is a
term in navigation in which you
determine the current position of a
moving object by using a previous
position and incorporating estimate to
speed heading in time it is subject to
human error and that's why GPS has
really rendered it obsolete but in this
Brave New World of the evil entity dead
reckoning is all you have to go by this
evil entity tricks the Russians into
thinking another sub has finally spotted
them and they fire on this Phantom sub
but it's really a ghost in the machine
there was no torpedo instead the only
dangerous torpedo is the one they fired
it Loops back on them kablooey
presumably The Entity did this because
it recognized that here under the Arctic
Ice would be the hardest place for
anyone to access the original server it
looked around and was like it's cold
it's deep here here will be my tomb we
move on to Amsterdam where the IMF
delivery guide meets Ethan who steps out
of the shadows and tells him the code
India Zulu 245 Nathan hunt responds
Bravo echo 1-1 which was the exact same
secure code that he gave you the 1996
film and came back in 2015's Rogue
Nation so Bravo Echo 1-1 be11 when you
mirror that and turn it into numbers
that look like the letters you get one
one three eight a nod to thx1138 the
first film of George Lucas who is a very
close friend to Brian De Palma Brian De
Palma of course directed that first
mission Impossible film and he wrote The
Star Wars opening crawl Ethan's Mission
recording recounts his formative moment
30 years prior a mission in Madrid in
which he witnessed Gabriel isai Morales
killing another agent now this would
have been a few years before the events
of the 1996 film and our writer Gina
Polito told me that Tom Cruise
apparently is the only movie star to
have in his contract that he can never
be scanned or be de-aged in a movie like
everything he will always do it
practically by refusing to age and this
is despite the actor Morales being DH in
these flashbacks notice how Tom Cruise
is only ever shown in Shadow because he
cannot will not digitally de-age himself
so Ethan goes looking for ilsa Foust
Rebecca Ferguson returning this movie
now hiding in the Arabian Desert near
the yemeni border another sandstorm
looms and you know Ethan is like didn't
I already fight one of these in Ghost
Protocol as ilsa Snipes the other
assassins she wears an eye patch and
Rebecca Ferguson revealed that this is
just because the actor couldn't wink her
left eye while peering through the scope
he lined up the shot I took it I was
ready I was breathing and he goes now
close your eyes and I went
hahaha
okay other shot other angle close the
eye can we get an eye patch Ethan finds
Elsa dead we think and then we jump to
this intelligence briefing filled with
familiar faces Mark Gaddis plays the NSA
head he's of course Mycroft from
Sherlock and the head of the iron bank
and Game of Thrones if your Varma leads
the DIA also from Game of Thrones and
Obi-Wan Kenobi A bunch of roles freaking
Rob Delaney shows up leading the jsoc
and Charles Parnell leads the NRL after
recently playing warlock top gun
Maverick Carrie Elvis plays denlinger
the Director of National Intelligence
they all discuss how the entity has
spread through all defense systems and
become sentient but so far only leaving
fingerprints send a message which
denlinger sums up as I shall return
perhaps quoting general Douglas
MacArthur who said these words in the
Philippines in World War II and later in
October 1944 returned and said I have
returned while he does this denlinger
looks out over rows and rows of
intelligence Personnel typing in analog
typewriters so that they have hard
copies of everything because they can't
trust any computer system just one of
many examples of this movie rewinding
the clock to Classic Espionage tropes
instead of one that takes place in the
digital age but the last intelligence
head to speak up is kid rich Henry's
Ernie returns for the very first time
from the 1996 film Journey told uprox's
Mike Ryan in an interview that after
that first film he actually met with CIA
consultants and came up with a ton of
ideas for where to go with his character
in inevitable next film and he pitched
these to Tom Cruise's producing partner
Paula Wagner And while she was very
polite and pay for the meal he was just
never asked to return after that but
he's back now and he's so good in this
movie also on the wall of this film is a
photo of Angela Bassett as Erica Sloan
kittridge's predecessor the CIA director
for Mission possible Fallout kitridge
brings up the IMF and then linger's like
what's that the international monetary
fund because that is what the IMF is
known as in the real world and everyone
in the room just kind of talks about how
ridiculous the IMF is Charles Parnell
talks about how agents have the option
to decline missions explaining that in
order to guarantee deniability agents
should only accept missions they can get
done meanwhile the rogue agent get rich
refers to is actually Ethan and he's
disguised out of focus in the background
behind him he gives him a gas mask he
stuns the room we flash back to the MN
border and we learn that Elsa is not
dead they faked it but Ethan does tell
her you're dead you stay dead and in
this movie Elsa will end up staying dead
and yeah it kind of sucks now long time
new Rockstar's viewers know how much we
use geology and how long we've been
using it for but if this is your first
time hearing about geology get ready for
Blockbuster quality skincare on a
student film budget geology is a 23-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oil-ness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you gotta do is take a quick
30 second quiz right now if you use the
code new rockstars 100 geology will give
you 100 off their award-winning skincare
trial set you'll also get additional
bonus offer of up to thirty percent off
one skin hair or body products when you
add it to your trial it's truly a wild
offer one of the best they've ever given
our audience so click the link in the
description or go to
geolog.i.e
rockstars100 to get started kittridge
warns Ethan the next World War isn't
going to be a cold one it's going to be
a shooting War it's going to be a
ballistic War over a rapidly shrinking
ecosystem it's gonna be a war for the
last of our dwindling energy drinkable
water breathable air and considering of
the last four Mission Impossible movies
we've had two freaking dust bowls maybe
this does hit with Ethan director
Christopher Macquarie in this movie uses
a lot of close-ups with Dutch angles
switching Kittredge from the left to the
right side of frame echoing Brian De
Palma stylized camera work in the 1996
movie and maybe all the close-ups are
just results of the fact that they shot
this movie during covid and didn't want
to put two people next to each other in
the same frame which is why sometimes in
this movie The Eye lines are just a
little bit off but it's also just
stylized and fun let's get over it in
the United Arab Emirates a Wiggum plays
Jasper Briggs so much fun watching this
movie he briefs his team telling them
not to underestimate Ethan Hunt to only
trust that he's dead if he stabbed at
the chest with a wooden stake which has
got to be a joke about Tom Cruise's
agelessness the guy is a total Vampire
Ethan meets up with Luther and Benji
Benji freaks out about a digital
parasite destroying the world before
quipping well it was bound to happen
sooner or later we're calling his
paranoid fear about the rabbit's foot in
Mission Impossible 3 something worn to
him over and over as a grad student when
he was dead Oxford Luther hacks Briggs
the unit's facial recognition software
and I love how several times in this
movie Riggs gropes around someone's face
to see if it's a mask meanwhile Benji
and Luther's computer gets hacked by The
Entity and I love how this movie does
not even wait for the entity to arrive
this is a world we live in right now it
sets us in constant paranoia Ethan bumps
into Grace Haley Atwell who snatched the
key and he snatches it back revealing it
with a sleight of hand it's a sort of
callback to when Ethan did slide a hand
with a disc to full Krieger in the 1996
film when Krieger really had the actual
list the whole time I think Tom Cruise
just likes to show off his close-up
magic skills Benji tracks down the
suspicious bag with a cryptex designed
just for him you are done his last name
is d u n n the first answer is out the
second one Are You Afraid Of Death he
has to say yes the third what is always
approaching but never arrives tomorrow
or who or what is most important to you
he says his friends fifth what gets
bigger the more you take away a whole
and the last one is blank but he has to
just look under it and realize it spells
out good luck I try to figure out if
there was like a mnemonic device or
something acrostic with these letters
but I'm gonna be paying close attention
to part two because I feel like these
riddles are gonna come back Ethan sees
Gabriel in the augmented reality
sunglasses on the reflection which
throws off his awareness allowing Grace
to snatch the key back he doesn't notice
because she replaces it with the lighter
that he let her keep offsetting the
weight Ethan will later use this lighter
the same exact way to fool Gabriel on
the train later so really this is a
trick he learned from her in Rome Grace
gets away from Ethan and he chases her
through the streets but they get
attacked by the group led by the
Assassin Paris Palm Clementi who's so
good in this movie I love how we see
grace days from the car wreck initially
in Ethan's insane heroic stunts of
taking out paris's guys with a
motorcycle all seen from her point of
view the same kind of thing happens with
Ethan's surprise landing on the train
car later with a parachute like we've
seen enough of these movies to know how
badass he's been Hunt is this time we
get to see more of his WTF surprise
moves through the eyes of a normal
person in this sequence Ethan handcuffs
himself to Grace but only on his left
hand assuming that he'll need his right
hand because he's right-handed but
immediately it becomes a big problem
because when he tries to stripe the car
Grace is hanging off of his left side
out the door they switch into a tiny
yellow Fiat and they swerve to avoid a
baby carriage and in the role as they
double down the steps somehow we end up
with Grace back in the driver's seat
they end up in the Metro tunnel and
Grace having swiped the paper clip from
the passport earlier only now uses it to
pick the lock on the handcuffs showing
that she waited until Ethan could get
her to safety away from the gunfire
Ethan rejoins Benji and Luther and ilsa
so much for staying dead Elsa and she
will be soon enough perhaps so mad she
dies in this movie they discuss an
upcoming meeting with the white widow
Alana midstopoulos Vanessa Kirby
returning from Fallout she's a daughter
to Max from the first film played by
Vanessa Redgrave Benji asks if the white
widow still thinks that Ethan is the
murderer John Mark and Ethan quips who
says I'm not and I love this because in
Fallout they never really answered that
question for Alana at least and I think
as viewers it's okay to have a bit of
suspicion that Ethan might still have
been the mythical John Lark figure I
know I know call me crazy it's Henry
cavill's character but I think we killed
the wrong one we're sorry we killed 200
Capital you're so good at that movie
with your magic pocket Luther brings up
the video that Ethan scanned through
sunglasses in the airport and sees in a
store mere reflection or one shot of
Gabriel an otherwise invisible man it's
a clever bit of VFX commentary I think
because remembering to remove and add
things from Reflections that are
captured on set is just one of the most
painstaking parts of the VFX job Ethan
realizes that all of Elsa's MI6
Communications that she was disavowed
were done digitally from an anonymous
source and they realized suddenly that
she might have been manipulated here by
the entity to join Ethan in fact The
Entity may have been using all of
Ethan's friends to get to him and
everyone starts second guessing
everything I love how Macquarie tilts
the camera more and more Dutch as they
get confused and bigger in the scene but
either way they head to Venice where
there's a party with some awesome lights
digital screens everywhere we later
learn these lights and screens are the
entity itself it's fitting that it takes
the shape of an eye as it's the eye of
God digital evil God it recalls the ring
shape the representation of the rehoboam
soft software in Westworld season 3.
he's essentially the same thing at least
when it comes to predicting people's
life paths but in this case it's not
grounded in one server in the desert I
love how throughout this meeting that
entity eye just kind of lingers in the
background just over Tom Cruise's
shoulder in plain sight and gradually
reveals itself to Ethan just prove it
was with him the entire time now these
kind of parties and fancy events are
totally a trophy Mission Impossible
movies it started with the Prague party
in the 1996 film and we saw another
party in Mission possible three and
responsible four they switched it up in
five in Rogue Nation when they went to
an opera but then there was the other
big party that the Halo jumped down to
Mission Impossible 6. at this party we
see Alana's brother Zola played by
Frederick Smith also returning this
world from Fallout all the big players
join in this meeting led by Alana who
still calls Ethan John Lark because yeah
she never learned his real name Gabriel
says that by the end of the night Ethan
will lose either Grace or ilsa and
Gabriel will end up with his half of the
key Gabriel says it is written which is
a common idiom from the Bible and
fitting for a man named Gabriel after
God's Archangel but also becomes a bit
of an antithesis to the theme for the
film Lawrence of Arabia where Lawrence
often says nothing is written The Entity
hacks the comms and pretends to be Benji
misdirecting Ethan and causing him to
lose both Grace and ilsa and I just love
how creepy it is when the voice melts
from Benji to something closer to
Gabriel and it says you are done we're
calling back the you are done that Benji
saw in the cryptex composer Lauren balth
in this movie does a really cool effect
of the music every time the entity
appears inverting the normal score now
the normal score in this movie is of
course based on Lalo shipper's iconic
classic theme
The Entity music inverts that
going from down to up and doing
something creepy creepy minor key so
during the fight Ethan allows Paris to
live a choice that will pay off in the
end perhaps a choice that the entity did
not initially see coming while fighting
Gabriel on the bridge Elsa displays her
patented legs around the neck take down
Gabriel's a step ahead of her stabbing
her in the leg pretty smart move akin to
a pro wrestler targeting the part of the
body that the opponent uses as a
finisher and so Elsa has left for dead
on this bridge pissing me off because
why would you bring Rebecca Ferguson
back into this movie just to kill her
off yeah okay okay but Ethan finding
that body on the bridge gotta be tough
for him since his teammates in the 96
movie also died on a bridge so they
enlist Grace to help them promising her
that she can go to get Ridge and say
that I said yes to the choice and they
give her a Vanessa Kirby mask like in
the past films there is an impossible
how did they do this shot that's all
done practically using subtle body
doubles the actors in a fake mirror
taking a shot that would be really easy
to do with bfx it's something that the
audience doesn't even notice initially
it puts a lot of effort into pulling it
off so check it out we don't see Haley
Atwell put on the mask in frame the
camera kind of pivots around her head
and then follows just a blonde wig up to
this cracked and distorted glass mirror
and then on the other side of that
mirror they have the real Vanessa Kirby
walking up from the other side so it's
not a mirror it's just a pane of glass
with a tilted room on the other side but
since his mirror glass is broken that is
really the how do they do this part
because they had to design a special
pane of glass that looked like it was
broken and distorted and that's assuming
that they did use VFX which I really
don't think they did I'm gonna be really
sad if they just did this with VFX
because doing the Practical mask stuff
is just part of the mission impossible
tradition I think Christopher mccordy
knows that okay so Luther departs for
the Final Act fun not to have him with
us but he's likely going to be playing a
bigger role in the next movie he tells
Ethan though not to kill Gabriel because
if he does the entity would win the
suitcase Mass printer breaks for the
mask for Alana's brother so even as it
goes protocol just has to improvise
bringing this to the final act on a
train as it was for the Final Act of the
1996 film Grace swaps places with the
real Alana and you can always tell
because real Alana has crystal blue eyes
Graces brown eyes and props to Vanessa
Kirby for doing an impression of Grace
doing an impression of her for such an
extended scene Benji finds an alternate
path for Ethan to make the jump leading
to the big old stunt of this movie
probably seen the various featurettes of
this big jump and yes it's insane Tom
Cruise actually did it practically but
one detail I love is that right before
Ethan revs up the motorcycle to hit the
gas Tom Cruise does this little head
shake to shake away his tragic memories
it's an acting choice to show him
shaking away his fear but Tom Cruise
said in an interview that this is also a
signal to the camera guy that he was
about to go because the timing had to be
perfect Tom Cruise's face to be in focus
on the jump really the only VFX in the
shot was the work to paint over the ramp
to make it look like it was part of a
cliff but I like out here rather than
stay with Ethan all the way down like we
saw with a Halo jump and Fallout we cut
back to Grace with the Alana mask after
her meeting with kittrich we don't see
Ethan until he Glides through the window
on the dining car to take out Zola's guy
that way it makes his Landing a complete
surprise and a hilarious punch line now
it's interesting to note that kitchen's
plan to meet with Alana the White Widow
while denling or Carrie elois plan to
meet with Gabriel revealing that the
United States created The Entity and
just got away from them and perhaps that
whole intelligence briefing early on in
the film wasn't really telling denlinger
anything new that's why he was facing
away from the other intelligence Chiefs
you didn't want to give away a tell as
Ethan fights Gabriel Grace runs through
every train car all the way to the
engine giving us a little preview of
every train car on the strain that she
could eat them will later have to climb
back through she passes through the bar
car with a piano then the dining car
then the kitchen bar with boiling grease
and so later after the bridge explodes
and the engine goes over detaching the
other cards we think the movie's over
but no no no no my friends inertia is a
real thing and I have never seen a slow
train crash where the threats are just
inertia and gravity and loose in an
inverted train car it's so much fun
apparently they built each car
practically and it totally pays off it's
my favorite sequence of the film it
reminded me of the averted trailer in
the Lost World Jurassic Park or the
inverted hallway an Inception it's so
fun to have one set that characters
fight through and turning the whole
thing on its axis the film ends with
Paris and her dying breaths telling them
where to find the entity source code on
the Sebastopol submarine hopefully pump
lemon Thief isn't dead because her
character was so much fun in this movie
I'd love to see her come back to the
next one but as we're headed to a
submarine yeah yeah to stop the stunts
of this movie you know Tom Cruise is
gonna have to do some crazy free dive
live in part two please don't die on us
Tom hey I want to thank our writers Gina
ippolito and Jordan Morris for their
research help on this as well as some
contributions by Brandon Barrick who is
a huge Mission possible nerd subscribe
to all three channels in the new
rockstars Network I'm doing some classic
breakdowns on the Deep dive but here on
the main new rockstars Channel I'm going
to be breaking down the Easter eggs in
every title you love all the current
releases we have some exciting stuff
ahead this week follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign